what we have on the table is the strong
sense of the disparities in wealth and
poverty and all the ways that affects
people and a strong sense that the
environment is is really at stake and
future and a woman yes I think you know
you're right because I see a lot of
people college students graduate
students who really are paying a lot of
attention to what is going on in the
world and how do they get the
information is probably a question that
I'm asking myself for example our
village earthworks which is a new
organization working in a country that
is off the map I don't know how many
people know the country Burundi and the
few occasions I'm at the airport JFK and
show my passport before I became US
citizen and this is immigration agent
asked me what is the what is that they
said well this is my passport which
country is that and they said it's
burundi where I made a terrible mistake
for saying that he said are you sure
it's not Roman that was that was what he
said and they said well it was brune
doin when I left I was exhausted in the
but I forgot that I was not yet a US
citizen so I end up somewhere I don't
want to talk about the garage so we how
do you this young students college
students get that information about the
earthworks access to internet what
universities are offering then they sit
down they Google I'm interested in
health speaking of health or
environmental issues and if we have one
worded that is the boom it's there and
then they contacted us if you know email
people who are working with that they
are interested in finding out gosh this
is amazing how many people are dying
because they have no clean water for
exam
in place like this and they really learn
so much about themselves through port is
available in internet depending on know
what they are of course googling and I
think I think they are really they have
the tools available which are given to
them by universities continued residence
a lot of resources available and you
know we see a lot of people who really
were so engaged they think they have a
lot of help the faculty the you know you
know access to a lot of information
that's but you would add you would add
that young people are highly motivated
by a much bigger global sense of the
world and responsibilities to the world
I mean you see that in your project
absolutely yeah I see that alone we have
a lot of medical students yeah college
students spending taking even a year
from school they go and see well let me
see what is happening and they stay
there longer I am going to ask for
permission you know try to find the ways
I can you know yes do something good
here and these really hates to do you
know when I was a student at chrome
University I had a hard time explaining
to my fellow classmates what it was to
be a poor person from a small country
one of the poorest countries in the
world what does it mean actually to be
someone like me who saw someone with
shoes when I was 16 what does it mean I
cared about what do I have food do when
I get sick what you know do I have
access to care or ifs raining it's
leaking the roof is leaking what would
you know where do I go so these are very
difficult situation to
explain to people who are around here
and the user would I say they would like
to take a trip to to Brody with me once
they get there they actually learn so
much about who they are yeah through
what they are seeing around and each one
of them each one of them has been
advocate works and has been in touch
with the community over there his no
combat completely changed in the Commons
talk about that literally as I'm
listening and of course we know this but
another thing that's changed is that we
as universities are recruiting a much
more international population of
students so when I was an undergraduate
having somebody from California as a
roommate was really exotic and and now
you know students from all over the
world are together so the dialogue
changes the learning is extended in a
very tangible and important way I also
think the coursework is different we had
very few comparative you know history or
comparative economics or things that
really made us focus on a wider world
except the history of the world and I
think that with the change in coursework
and the internet universities have
really expanded brought the world into
the classroom right and bought and
brought students really into the world